live from new york it's
kim kardashian and pete davidson going
on a date
i mean i like you just the way you are
just weeks after the pair made headlines
for sharing a smooch during a skit on
snl now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
e.t has learned they're back in the big
apple and spending time together i love
that a source tells et that kim and pete
hung out in the comedian's native staten
island grabbing a bite at one of his
favorite spots italian restaurant
campania we're told the duo is enjoying
their time together and they're having
fun specifically they've bonded over
being newly single pete recently split
from bridgeton star phoebe dinova and
kim filed for divorce from kanye west in
february it's a different experience for
sure
speaking of kanye it seems kim is
keeping the rapper in mind as she gets
to know pete better outsource saying
quote kim has also been protective of
kanye and his feelings and has been
trying to keep their hangouts low-key
because she doesn't know how he will
react him and i have been best friends
for a really long time as for kim and
pete's relationship status well a second
source says despite trying to play it
off like they're just friends it's a
little more than that adding that they
like each other quote they're having a
lot of fun together pete makes kim laugh
and makes her feel special pete is
obviously thrilled and has a major crush
on kim and get this
that's kim's security guard outside her
manhattan hotel on tuesday bringing in a
large floral delivery of red roses it's
unclear who sent the stunning
arrangement but they arrived just as the
reality star was about to leave for her
dinner date with pete i'm just a little
concerned that
physically
i can't handle you
[Music]
if we go all the way
he might like break me the pair's latest
outing comes just days after they hung
out at knott's scary farm along with
some friends including kim's sister
courtney and her fiance and friend of
pete's travis barker
[Music]
the group went on several rides where
kim and pete paired off and shared a
cart by themselves on one of the park's
many roller coasters and if you look
closely you'll see kim
clutching onto pete's hand
[Music]